[Music]  to dream to seek the unknown to look for  what is beautiful is its own reward a  man's reach should exceed his grasp or  what's a heaven for  you are the Explorer give me a hint  I wish to find a lost city  what you seek is far greater than you  ever imagined  it is your destiny  you not know you when you return I know  this is a sacrifice for all of us the  environments brutally difficult the  journey may well mean your life but you  could reclaim your family name ain't  nobody comes back from up there but we  have never let fear determine our future  that you hope to achieve out here  if we may find the hidden civilization  where one was considered impossible to  exist we may well write a whole new  chapter in history  I call it set it is there and we must  find it  [Music]  the dreams we got a gold mine  we ought to go by we believe you're  [ __ ] on the